we've been separated for several months
what
so are you separated yes we're separated
Janelle and Cody Brown reveal they're
separated
Janelle has made it pretty clear to me
that she's
enjoying her life without me I think
there was a lot of challenges and it
played out in
in just as complicated way in our family
as it does in the bigger sphere the
bombshell gets dropped in the teaser for
the upcoming Sister Wives one-on-one
special the two separating after being
spiritually married for 29 years I think
if we both really sat down we'd look at
each other and say really we've been
separated for several months what
so are you separated yes we're separated
and Christine who left Cody last
November and is close to Janelle gives
deeper insight into Janelle's thought
process
for Janelle I think that she's
frustrated and she's so hurt and that
man that she was married to she realizes
that he's totally different but she's
different too the couple's Rocky
Relationships been playing out this
season on the TLC series including their
big disagreements on their living
situation we've been in Flagstaff for
four freaking years and I don't have a
house still I've been pushing this house
of Christine's on to Janelle for a long
time and Janelle's like stop it she
doesn't want to buy Christine's house
she wants to build her own house
he's not listening at all I'm trying to
be a husband a father to their children
and a lover to two people who may not
see eye to eye that's a little challenge
yeah and those challenges caused both
Janelle and Cody to question their
marriage but the last few years I've
begun to wonder if we're compatible
anymore maybe this doesn't
work anymore for me I don't know and
maybe just person maybe this is not a
good fit maybe this doesn't work it's
unclear if Janelle will follow in
Christine's footsteps leaving the plural
marriage to Cody Robin and Mary but
there's no doubt Christine and Janelle
will be supporting each other through it
all I'm super close to now that's that's
of course very different uh just Janelle
and I are to probably just continue I
don't know if you can be Sister Wives
you know if you're not really but I just
consider telling my sister like she just
thought this will be
[Music]
foreign